[موسيقى]
تعلمون أننا كنا مواطنين تمامًا مثل
أي شخص آخر
ويجب أن نتمتع بنفس الحقوق التي يتمتع بها
[موسيقى]
الآن ، تذكر الآن أنني أبلغ من العمر 11 عامًا ، قررنا
السير عبر الجسر
الذي ما زلت لا أملكه  تعرف أن أي شيء
كنا نسير فيه كان مجرد
مسيرة أخرى ، تعلمون أن
الهجوم وقع هنا وليس على
الجسر
نقول الجسر لأنه
أقرب
معلم حيث بدأنا في رؤية
رجال الشرطة
ونعتقد أن شيئًا ما لم يكن صحيحًا
لأنه
حتى من هنا أنت  يمكن أن نرى أنه كان
عددًا كبيرًا من رجال الشرطة ، ليس فقط نواب العمدة
والنواب
ولكن جنود الدولة وكل
شيء كان هنا ، ثم رأينا
خيولًا كانت غير عادية
ما اعتقدت أنها طلقات نارية وصراخ
اعتقدت أنها كانت تقتل الناس
في المقدمة
لأنهم  من الطلقات النارية لكن
اتضح أنها ليست طلقات نارية ، لقد كان
الغاز المسيل للدموع
أولاً هو الصراخ الطلقات الأولى بالقرب من
ثم وصلنا الغاز المسيل للدموع وكان
الناس يجرون عائدين نحونا
وقمنا بتصحيح الخطأ.  لقد
جاءوا من كلا
الجانبين من الأمام والخلف
وكانوا يضربون الناس فقط
ويبدو أنه استمر إلى الأبد
إذا تمكنت من
التغلب على هؤلاء الرجال سيرًا على الأقدام ، فلن تتمكن من
الجري على الخيول ، كان الأمر فظيعًا في
ذلك اليوم كان أفظع  يوم من حياتي ،
ما حدث مع وفاة السيد فلويد
ورأيناه يموت في الوقت الفعلي
أنه لامس غدًا بوصلة
أمريكا
يعقوب أصيب في ظهره سبع مرات
من قبل ضابط شرطة
وأود أن أشكر الجميع على
الخروج لدعم  ابني
مع محاولة القتل الحمقاء
التي ارتكبت عليه
وعندما رأيته كانت عيناه
مفتوحتين
على الرغم من أنه كان في حالة من فقدان
الوعي عندما رآني كان أه
يحدق
وقلت إنك تعاني من ألم شديد يا حبيبي
وقال لا ، أردت فقط التأكد من وجود
نظامين للعدالة في
الولايات المتحدة هناك
عدالة للبيض ومن
ثم هناك فقط
نحن عام 2020 وما زلنا نتحدث
عن تسجيل الناخبين
وخسارة الناس من التصويت
2020 أخي وأنا ما زلت جالسًا
هنا نخبرك
أو يجب أن أخبر الناس أن ابني
إنسان ، إنه
أخو 2020
وعلينا أن نخبر الناس أننا
جزء من الإنسانية
أن الحياة السوداء مهمة ، يجب أن
تعلم بالفعل
أنك